lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comprender cómo una compañía puede
comprar a otra o unirse con otra
mediante sus bienes tenemos una
situación aquí en la que la compañía ha
adquirido la compañía ve por 60 millones
en las acciones de ohl y lo que vamos a
ver es que esto no será exactamente 60
millones de dólares va a depender de en
cuánto se están vendiendo las acciones
ya y en este momento sus acciones se
venden a 30 dólares por cada acción para
poder llevar a cabo esa transacción en
las acciones de lo que sucede es que a
dice bueno necesito acumular el
equivalente a 60 millones en acciones
necesito crear el equivalente a 600
millones si cada una de mis acciones
valen en el mercado en este momento 30
dólares puedo lograr esto creando o
emitiendo 2 millones de acciones así que
la compañía va a crear o emitir otros 2
millones de acciones y si lo quisieran
hacer como una transacción de efectivo
podrían tomar estas acciones y venderlas
en el mercado como uno
secundaria y con suerte venderlas en
efectivo y usar ese efectivo para
comprar la compañía vez pero esta es una
oferta de acciones y no una transacción
en efectivo lo que van a hacer esto
directamente siempre y cuando la
compañía ve esté de acuerdo les van a
dar las acciones directamente a la
compañía ve oa los dueños de la compañía
ve a cambio de esencialmente tomar
control de estas acciones de la compañía
ve toma de estos dos millones de
acciones que en este momento en el
mercado parecen valer 60 millones y se
lo van a dar a los accionistas de la
compañía ve a cambio de las acciones
existentes de la compañía ve así pues lo
que va a pasar es que la compañía le va
a dar a la compañía ve 2 millones de
acciones de la compañía que se la da a
la compañía ve y a cambio la compañía ve
todos los accionistas de la compañía ve
les darán sus acciones a la compañía a
van a dar un millón de acciones a la
compañía a cambio de esos dos millones
de acciones de la compañía
lo que va a pasar es que cada uno de los
accionistas de la compañía ve van a
recibir dos acciones de la compañía
por cada acción que tengan de la
compañía ve por lo que van a tener dos
acciones lo pongo en verde
de hada por cada acción
m
de la que son dueños y eso tiene sentido
económicamente porque el precio que
tienen actualmente en el mercado digamos
que es de 50 por acción y tiene un
conjunto de 50 millones en el mercado al
ofrecerles 60 millones en acciones dado
el precio que tienen pues esto les va a
convencer a los accionistas de vender
sus acciones ya que están recibiendo un
20% por encima del precio del mercado y
por cada acción que tú tienes vas a
recibir dos acciones que valen en el
mercado 30 cada una así que pues parece
un buen negocio para los de la compañía
ve cambiar una cosa que vale 50 dólares
por dos cosas que valen 30 cada una y en
total valen 60 dólares y si los
accionistas de la compañía lo aceptan
entonces va a pasar que aquel millón de
acciones ese millón de acciones de la
compañía de va a ser puesta en el lado
de los bienes de la compañía y aquí
ponemos
la compañía ve ya que todas las acciones
de esta compañía están bajo el control
de la compañía a otra manera de haber
llevado a cabo esto es haber vendido
estas acciones en el mercado esos 60
millones de dólares y después darles
este dinero directamente a los
accionistas y hubiéramos tenido
exactamente el mismo resultado